dans le viseur de moscou depuis
plusieurs semaines le sort de l'eau
ennjimi morial est désormais connue
l'organisme doit cesser toutes ses
activités
telles que leur donne la cour suprême du
pays on lui reproche de ne pas
s'identifier comme un agent étranger
qui pourtant à bien des activités en
france en belgique ou en allemagne dans
la russie de vladimir poutine ce statut
et contreversé désigne des organisations
qui reçoivent des fonds étrangers et qui
donc selon moscou agissent contre les
intérêts russes
c'est une décision malfaisante et juste
est très nuisible pour notre pays réagit
l'avocate de la défense pour cet autre
l'argument avancé était suffisant pour
ordonner la dissolution d'un organisme à
but non lucratif commandant en second le
haut et j'ai emblématique mémorial est
la principale organisation russe de
défense des droits humains l enquête
depuis plus de 30 ans sur les crimes
soviétique récence les répressions
contemporaine dont celle du régime de
vladimir poutine en plus de la loi dite
violé le parquet l'accuse de faire
l'apologie du terrorisme et de
l'extrémisme
une manifestation à d'ailleurs éclaté
devant le palais de justice au moins
cinq manifestants ont été arrêtés par la
police selon le média indépendant russe
ottavi jeunes
ces décisions de la cour suprême vient
conclure une année marquée par la
répression croissante des critiques du
président poutine au pouvoir depuis
bientôt 22 ans
deux alliés de l'opposant russe
emprisonné alexis navalni ont d'ailleurs
été arrêtés mardi dont une élue kenza
fall il va accuser d'extrémisme un crime
passible de 12 ans d'emprisonnement pour
sa part l' ong mémorial refuse de
baisser les bras et comptent trouver des
moyens légaux de poursuivre ses
activités ici daniel kadjo radio canada
montréal